The answer is that up here there's 8 different possibilities and down here, there's 16 possibilities.
Now, there's two ways to go about this.
One is to just do the counting, which can get very tedious at least in the graph down here,
or the other one is to figure out a general rule which could be quite helpful and that rule is that
any time that you want to move forward you have two different choices that you can make.
Once you start in A, there's two different choices. You can go either that way or that way.
If your say in this vertex here, you have two choices.
You can either stay up here or you can go down here.
Likewise when you're down here, you can go either this way or that way.
Each time you move forward, you can make one of two choices and since here,
you can make one of two choices except for the last time.
In the last move, you'll always have to end up at B, so here we have 1, 2, 3 times
that we can make two choices and then we cannot make a choice here anymore.
And 2³ is 8 and down here, it's basically the same thing.
We just have one more of these layers here where we can
make a choice and so that's going to be 2⁴ or 16.